hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to mountain now mountain is
an experimental game or it may not even
be considered a game at all and from
what I've heard and what I've seen
you literally observe the world as it
changes around you and apparently I'm
supposed to draw something that makes me
happy or reminds me of happiness there
we go that's what reminds me of
happiness a smiling face beauty Oh
beauty
uh there we go that's what I consider
beauty a nice spotted giraffe beautiful
and elegant and so weird God
oh man here we go that's an acceptable
appropriation of who I think God is Oh
patience I don't know if I have that
I'll try oh you are now being generated
oh welcome to Mountain you are mountain
you are God please enjoy your time here
so if you're waiting for me to do
something that's not the point of the
game the point Oh saving thank you for
saving I don't know what's gonna happen
but thank you
the point of the game is merely to
observe change as it happens and I
believe there's some randomly generated
elements into this and maybe I can oh
good I can zoom around so this is me I'm
not watching a mountain I am the
mountain I am the all power war warrant
rinse base why didn't anybody tell us we
were in space cuz that's all that's cool
oh that's cool why are we a mountain
floating in space I don't even know
what's keeping us together I don't know
anything about this but apparently I
have thoughts
I'm delighted by this gloomy day so am i
oh I love rainy days I really do I love
it when it's overcast in cloudy
which is bizarre cuz I live in LA and
it's never overcast in cloudy and it
never rains but I love rainy days
apparently now we're full screen which
is good I can't think of nothing greater
than today's utter perfection oh that's
some beacon of positivity stuff going on
there
I feel overjoyed by the sleepy day oh
I'm listening to the thoughts of a
mountain but this is one of those games
that it's impossible to see the meaning
from the surface of it you kind of have
to experiment in regards to what it is
and I don't know why I was drawing all
those pretty pictures earlier but this
is nice I don't know what to say oh well
I neither do I most of the time so I
just make something up and hope it
sounds cool what is the meaning of this
another good question I can't exactly
answer that for you you kind of have to
find out the answer for yourself also I
see asteroids about I see more things
orbiting around us or maybe I just
didn't notice them before and that is a
cool nebula oh I wish I lived in a space
barring Oh era although although
apparently mister Elon Musk is trying to
get colonization efforts to Mars under
way and if that happens I may just have
to abandon everything and go that way
oh there's fireflies oh there's
fireflies see this is what I mean by the
game when I say that the game is an anti
game a game in and of itself has certain
definitions and of course people could
argue what is a good game what is a game
period and what is a bad game but at its
heart a game is something that you want
to spend your time on and what like you
could spend your time on a lot of things
and that's not a general definition of a
game but I'm just saying at its most
basic thing a game is some
that you want to engage yourself in and
dedicate your time to and whether that's
actively playing or in this bizarre
world passively experiencing something
who's to say what's the game and what's
not a game I mean I don't know okay so I
was recommended this game and also sent
some associating little codes here that
can change what's going on in the game
so oh oh there's a rainbow a true
rainbow a rain circle because a rainbow
is actually a rain circle it's just that
the rest of the parabola connects with
the ground oh it's so cool oh that's
delightful anyway I got some codes here
that apparently will change the world
hey what's that
that is called snow globe mode and oh my
goodness that's cool oh that's nice so
apparently the buttons oh all the
buttons do something okay so this next
one's called
blood Oh oooh oh it's oh it's raining
blood hallelujah if it's raining blood
that's not good god it's really raining
blood you have anything to say about
this where am I good question but it's
Oh what was that what is that oh man you
know what you know a vibe I'm getting
out of this in a weird way I don't know
why but it's kind of like the choir
music and the fact that you're kind of
from a bird's eyes perspective and I've
been told that I'm a god did anybody
ever play the original black and white
like the first game in the series the
second game was pretty good but the
first game like really resonates with me
because it's one of my favourite games
and one that I
spent so much time and in the concept of
that you were in control of an entire
village that had free will and like
worshipped you whether you were good or
bad and you had moral choices about
things I really loved that aspect of
that game and maybe I'll do a live
stream about that game because I love
black and white it is a great game but
I'm just getting very weird vibes about
it and why is there a giant dice in the
mountain what did I do for that
[Music]
this one's called rain fur fish ah well
I suppose that's marginally better than
raining blood but I imagine that when
they hit the ground we're still gonna
have just as much blood oh that is oddly
pretty very fishy oh that's beautiful
oh that's beautiful
I like that oh it's like a little
glockenspiel that I can play with oh
these frogs are coming in sideways oh
jeez oh no Pepe did you hear that you're
now a band meme nothing nothing not even
about the raining frogs oh this one's
called hearts ah is beautiful oh it's
beautiful
I'm kind of concerned about this next
one I won't tell you what it is before
it happens but here we go
Oh oh no oh no oh oh no it was called
flames Oh
oh that's oh is it actually gonna burn
anything up okay we're good
I'm absorbing this autumn morning I
didn't know that it was autumn and also
still meteor shower from space this poor
planet it's like I'm playing SimCity and
just accidentally put all the disasters
on it once accidentally GABA Gold rain
there we go
gold rain oh that's delightful ooh
that's nice so I suppose that as you're
playing more and more objects hit your
mountain from space and your mountain
gets customized in this aspect and I
don't know it
oh oh that's I can have all of them oh
no I can't I definitely can't have all
of them I just have to pick one at a
time
well I'll do the hearts one cuz that was
pretty oh it is autumn the leaves are
falling off oh that's cool okay this is
the last one that I'm saving here it's
uh mmm uh-oh oh hi
Oh God oh geez on my Mountain I never
loved my Mountain oh I didn't beat so
tortures and slow Oh God oh this is my
fault
oh geez oh you died by the era of
infinite pain and sorrow is that just
floating out in space or did it hunt me
down
oh my kidding I did it to myself well
there you have it
death well death sure is a [ __ ]
yep I done goofed it a done goofed it
privacy how do I draw sewing
masturbating ooh no mom no that's what I
call modern art childhood uh me oh no
mom no and there you have it my
childhood oh man you're now being
generated thank you is this Oh slightly
different welcome to Mountain your
Mountain you are God oh it's a slightly
different mountain I've got a bit of a
steeper slope on me whoo I've got a
hefty slope yeah all the lady Mountains
are gonna like me okay but anyway that
is Mountain so there may be other
secrets to this game that I am not 100%
sure of they may be you there may be
more of a story to the thoughts of the
mountain than I know but all I know is
that this is very interesting and
fascinating and I am totally into games
like this so if you want to play this
for yourself it's only 99 cents on Steam
go check it out through the link in the
description below and thank you
everybody for watching also let me know
what you think it means to be a mountain
in space thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]